so I did want to talk about over watch
the new 3v3 elimination mode Jake you
and I played together a lot over the
weekend I don't know how many total
hours and that was my first
reintroduction to overwatch since I
think Anna and I wasn't playing i played
on a little bit in this mode but Joey
you got into play summer you did a few
live streams for us I played somber for
the first time with 3v3 mode and I can't
want to talk about it see how it changes
up the overwatch formula and also like
whether you agree with me that this is
your favorite way to play overwatch now
I know we had talked about a little bit
before and there are kind of some
nuances to it that make that a little
complicated question but I don't I want
to start off that well how much 3v3 mode
have you played Joe I played not a whole
lot a couple couple matches with my
friends maybe totaling close to about
two hours okay um and for the most part
you know we stuck to a pretty pretty
basic formula you know one healer one
tank 1 damage dealer yeah which tends to
work pretty well um and that might
actually be the problem I think it can
work too well in the sense that i love
these other characters that aren't gonna
do well in three of you three just won't
get played right yeah that's the thing
with us we were playing and we kind of
switch it up every once in a while like
if we were ahead by it so it's best
first of three wins and so but it's also
elimination obviously so I mean I got
like so bad yeah that changes up a lot
cuz you only have one life yeah you're
more from survival yeah and so like but
that's the thing with like a lot of
people I see a ton of Road hogs I see a
lot as areas i mean Road hogs and mercy
yeah I see a lot of like in terms of
people that can heal themselves road hog
bastion may sorry I just auto heals it
was my favorite character so I was
playing her the whole time it does kind
of exclude certain heroes from being
played a lot doesn't exclude them but i
mean i don't know i went in with mccurry
a few times and didn't feel like I was
doing much like he would have been a
good damage dealer because we had like
someone playing road hog we had someone
playing you know Mercy Mercy is kind of
like the go through healer for this mode
because you can get her alt and I think
the map is small enough where if she
does her all and revives people it's
pretty much the entire map almost yeah
it is one map antarctica what do you
Jake what do you think of the map
I mean I i think the map is fine like
what I'm more interested in is just the
dynamic of 3v3 that's what I have that's
what I was having fun with it would have
been really nice to have at least
another one because like you said we
played this like I don't know five hours
straight yeah we just play an art to go
over and over again yeah it's pretty
much so I eventually I ended up playing
a lot of hon so oddly enough cuz I you
know he's like spread arrow works really
well and like the tight quarters and the
other buildings but right away I would
fire the Recon a sonar arrow into like
the other building on the other side and
if I didn't see no bike-o they're
probably over here and then at one point
I fired over there they weren't there
like oh they're probably in our building
were like where the hell is everyone and
we searched this very small map for
about like 30 seconds all right what's
happening did what's going on with this
game they had camps right the spawn with
a reinhart and then a bastion set up
behind him and their mercy so they was
waiting for us to come to them so we
have smoked if we didn't really realize
what they were doing the best and just
mowed us down once we figured out what
was going on we kind of just like when
in that's there's a side tunnel that
leads into their spawn hangar and I
think he's lobbed grenades and there's
junk yeah it becomes kind of a its I do
like the dynamic of it's almost like
maybe not rock paper scissors but there
are like some psychological games you
could play with people like they did
that twice well they're gonna do a third
time but then one of us was like no
there's no way they'll do three times
around they didn't they actually came
out as like Genji and honza or someone
but I do i do like the fact that his
elimination it makes me think more about
what i'm about to do i'll be way more
focused on surviving than I normally
would I especially like I know Devo got
that buff recently so her health is up
to 600 if i'm not mistaken so we had a
lot of divas like you said Joey there's
a lot of tanks going on like what uh I
don't know like what character are you
playing oh I played mostly as junk Rhett
just because I'm like pretty comfortable
with them um and he does I feel okay you
know he tends to work better with a lot
of people around them and just gain
randomly hit by grenades um but the more
the thing I'm more worried about is um a
lot of the other defensive characters
like torbjorn and even symetra even
though she's classified as de fit more
as support but she's a pretty defensive
character um people like that they're
not going to have as much use because
people are moving around the map so much
you know it's not gonna give them a lot
of time to set up and I feel like those
characters kind of be kind of fallen by
the wayside as far as 3v3 goes sure to
mention somber sorry symmetric quick
they got that update today which can
choose between two old now so she has a
shield generator which he can hide and
then it just shields everybody within a
really large radius Jeff Kaplan got on
the overwatch developer update a to talk
about that that could be way more useful
than the teleporter because again the
teleporter is mainly good for this is a
brief tangent I just like so Metro a lot
the teleporter is good for obviously
getting your team back to that first
capture point yeah then it becomes less
useful as a match goes on but I can see
that being huge especially on such a
small map like not only worried about
the other team but trying to find the
shield generator where it's hidden that
could be a really cool dynamic but um
yeah that's that's the one thing like I
don't see myself ever really using ohne
anymore in this mode she's not gonna do
enough damage to be the damage dealer
she's not gonna she doesn't heal fast
enough like mercy water lucio up close I
just don't it definitely kind of is
tailored to you know support certain
characters and uh luckily like the
characters I like are all kind of
favored in this mode between like Lucio
machree I don't know like Hanzo or just
mail again maybe like sorry as my main
and she does really well in this mode
early side he really well was aria yeah
although I thought zenyatta he's support
right cuz he was he was pretty deadly
like yeah he's probably the best healer
in 3v3 mostly because you're constantly
trying to hide in 3v3 so he can heal you
know he can heal behind walls and just
keep running away while poking at them
yeah and then Ultimates become really
valuable this cuz you know i'd say maybe
seventy five percent of matches and
before most people unless you're like I
don't know a tracer a mercy will have
their alts um so then when someone does
have her all especially like we said
mercy she's just if you're doing damage
to someone you want to make sure you're
trying to kill them because if you do
did enough damage them and then they
just run away and mercy heels I'm you're
just contributing to her all that's all
you're doing yeah so you really need to
like kind of plan out when you're gonna
attack I did find that again I was
wayward more worried than I usually I'm
about like what I'm about to do in this
mode and we played just regular 66 right
afterward we I think we just had a good
team but we felt like we did a lot
better I don't think we died like a lot
of us Jake when we were playing you're
definitely more concerned
like your movement what you're gonna do
you think things out a little bit more
yeah and it does like if you're trying
to hide later on it'll reveal the last
two players like 1v1 or fish is one
person left it'll reveal them and then
that becomes like kind of a matter of
just finding them when they're
highlighted through walls and whatnot is
running away mmhmm yeah I just trying to
run away especially if your diva you see
here diva just gets ejected and then
just pretty much waiting to get her Mac
back um I guess the main question want
to pose like this mode is here to stay
from what I believe right it's not just
like a like a event do you see this as
something you'll come back to a lot or
do you just kind of see this as a
one-off thing for you while you just
focus more on like payloads and yeah I
feel like it's for me is that for me
it's more of a one-off things more of
just like a fun thing if not everyone
not everyone my friends are online and
only three of us there and we'll do it
because you know they sense it's part of
the arcade mode you can go into this and
if you do get three wins you'll get a
loop box so there's in there is an
incentive to play these as opposed to as
far as I'm you know just wanting to get
into them um but I think what the game
with that mode offers more than anything
else is teaching people the importance
of their own life yeah cuz like you said
you know when when you know that you're
gonna die and you're not going to
respond for the rest of the match you're
gonna value it so much more yeah totally
it's a again that like kind of
especially if you're not playing like a
self-healing character or something like
that it definitely does make you
consider like we are actions a lot more
I'm not do you see playing 3v3 a lot
more Jake I think so I mean especially
though like kind of to set the stage
when we played it was like I to monitor
setup Mike and monitor setup and then
another person to monitor we're in the
same room like it screaming at each
other and like telling Nick margarita
Arthur that he sucks at overwatch yeah
so like I feel like that definitely adds
a lot I'd still play online with three
people i know but by myself I probably
wouldn't if it was just me I'd probably
go 66 it's definitely it's almost like
we're talk about gears were for horde
mode a lot lately and you and I played
that a little bit together and it does
seem like something that I wouldn't
value it as much if I wasn't playing
with like friends and like even like /
voice chat you definitely need voice
chat for this because I calling out
where everybody is like I'm about to all
if I'm mercy or someone even more so
than normal i think it's reliable like
mainly on communication and everything
but yeah i'm personally to play 3v three
a lot more and i can't wait to do that
as long as again i have friends but
anyway yeah cool well that is over
watches 3v3 elimination mode update yeah
you can play it now on consoles on pc
again it's pretty much it's pretty
intense but it is uh it's fun to wait
play I don't know try that out let us
know you think in the comments below